hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead inspired by
the real 2014 armed conflict between
Russia and Ukraine in the Damas region
today we're going to tell you a very
unique story about an ordinary teacher
who suddenly becomes the most lethal
sniper in the world just by utilizing
his knowledge in physics mccola a
physics teacher lives an eccentric
Countryside life with his pregnant wife
Nastia in the Dumbo's region of Ukraine
he goes to school and watches the news
that the Crimea region is captured and
Russians deploy snipers to Ukrainian
lands meanwhile at home Nastia creates
woodcrafts a small wooden amulet
depicting an angel while mccola teaches
a class bully Ivan spits a piece of
paper and disrupts the class although
Mercola can take control of the
situation after the lesson Ivan tells
mikola that he is an outsider due to his
eccentric upbringing mccola turns out to
be an academically gifted person he has
multiple degrees including an ecologist
he chooses to stay in an accent cabin in
the dombas region with his wife so they
would not disturb the environment they
are covered by a TV program but the host
seems uncomfortable with their eccentric
lifestyle and becomes reluctant despite
mercola's enthusiasm to show her his
house after the host and her cameraman
leave the house the couple continues
with their lives they bathe outside
under the Moonlight Nastia then gives
him her wooden amulet which she dubs
little angel in hopes that it can
protect her husband at the same time a
convoy of Russian militants crosses the
Ukrainian border near their house
the next day mccola goes to school as
usual but finds it closed because
Russian forces have reached the region
along the way to school he bumps into
two armed Russian men the men turn out
to stop by his house and accuse his wife
as a spy as she appears to be eccentric
and wears natural face paints they
torture the couple and burn their houses
as Nastia Rises to hit them with a rock
they shoot her to death they quickly get
in their vehicle and drive away while
Mercola Mourns his beloved wife after
his house is completely burned two local
men come by and check his identity after
being confirmed that he is a local they
help him bury his wife and take him to
their base arriving at the base mccola
is kept inside the car while his
Rescuers are scolded for bringing a
possible spy to the base camp however
the chief wants to train mikola after he
learns that mccola is determined to
drive away Russian militants from his
land he trains hard with the camp and
eventually Masters how to disassemble
and assemble an AK gun he wants to be
called raven inspired by his wife's
philosophy that a raven creates life on
Earth but his captain tells him the call
sign must be earned one day local
soldiers offer sniper courses so the
camp sends some volunteers mccola
demonstrates his ability to deal with an
AK gun blindfolded which attracts the
attention of Two Soldiers they enlist
him to join the course along with bad
climb and dunay however he is given an
SKS rifle unlike everyone else who gets
SVD he tries to question the decision
but is left unanswered he excels in his
training but finds it impossible to
shoot with his rifle however his captain
says that it is the sniper who matters
not the gun as snipers must calculate
distance quickly in their head he excels
as he is a former physics teacher at the
last exam he waits patiently until the
smoke Fades and gets a Clear Vision then
fires a shot he gets three points the
highest of his friends and graduates
with a first class degree
there's no time to rest makola begins
his first mission which is to recapture
a bridge as they aim for their targets
two civilians approach the bridge and
are harassed by the Russian forces they
silently execute the shot bringing down
several of the Russians but one of them
holds the civilian hostage after an
intense moment the surviving Russian is
also shot and they reoccupy the bridge
after the mission mikola returns to the
bay sand he then makes a quick
observation eventually realizing that
the base was previously a school
building he always reminisces about his
little angel during his rest time at the
base meanwhile dunay and Clem are
deployed to a mission in sand dunes the
mission is difficult as they are
head-to-head with Russian snipers which
are also difficult to spot in the dunes
Klim is shot dead his body is brought
back to Camp where his friends mourn for
him Ukrainian forces want to reoccupy a
trench at the zero line for the next
mission they set grenades between the
trees and wait until Russian soldiers
cross the tree line so they can fire the
trigger from afar and decimate the
Russians mccola realizes Ivan is among
the Russian soldiers the captain tells
him that both he and Ivan made their
choices they then go to the Russian
shelter finding Ivan's family photograph
it inspires them to talk about each of
their families and personal life
Captain's children only know that their
father is gone on a business trip
meanwhile Russian soldiers mobilize
further deep into Ukrainian grounds one
of them is a renowned Russian sniper
they mobilize using a convoy of
camouflaged Vehicles as mccola and
Captain take their position near the
trench they spot a camouflaged Russian
car and two militants nearby mccola
recognizes them as his wife's killers
driven by rage he repeatedly asks for
permission to shoot but the captain
denies it however he goes against the
order and shoots one of the militants
but the other one escapes hides behind
the car and informs the Russian sniper
of their location the captain is shot
dead Mercola carries his dead body
crawling to safety and drives him back
to the base at the base while mourning
for his captain McCullough is instructed
to deal with the sniper responsible for
his death they will look into the sniper
further he then goes for another mission
single-handedly defeating two Russian
snipers stationed in an abandoned
warehouse but he also gets shot in the
arm by one of the snipers while he
bathes his chief contacts him to inform
him that the Russian sniper has fired on
two Ukrainian Scouts he has to get ready
for a meeting for more details on the
location and Mission objective
the meeting is held at his old sniper
training camp they receive information
from intelligence that a Russian sniper
codenamed sarri was responsible for
Captain's murder along with other
Ukrainian soldiers he publishes murder
videos showing his victims to demoralize
ukrainians in this war he is currently
stationed with a group of observers near
a chlorine plant a missed shot by the
ukrainians would result in the explosion
of pressurized chlorines causing an
environmental disaster their Ambush has
to be discreet well planned and
carefully executed the other snipers are
tasked to neutralize the Russian
observers and series subordinates
clearing the way from a cola to get into
the factory and directly face sarri they
prepare for the mission and get ready at
their positions the Ukrainian snipers
are stationed on High Ground not far
from the chlorine plant as they observe
and acquire their targets as they
eliminate the Russian soldiers mccola
makes his way inside the factory then
spots sarri's second in command
stationed at the stairwell as sarri
calls for his soldiers and they do not
respond as they are already dead he
becomes alerted and calls his second in
command to meet with him upstairs mccola
secretly follows him placing a grenade
at the stairwell and hides somewhere at
the chlorine plant sarri discovers that
his sniper on the rooftop has been shot
then he deduces the Ukrainian snipers
are nearby he calls for backup a backup
team will retrieve him in 10 minutes so
he has to hold his ground first he goes
back inside the plant and assembles his
rifle then notices mercola's amulet
nearby suddenly mccola jumps from behind
and stabs him with a knife until he dies
from losing too much blood as for his
second in command it is too late when he
realizes there is a grenade at the
stairwell and it blows the mission is
successful however the Russian backup
troops arrive but the Ukrainian snipers
get The High Ground and can neutralize
the Russians Mercola helps by
assassinating them for from inside the
chlorine plant they all go home in one
piece and are ready to take on more
missions some time later mccola visits
his old now abandoned house and visits
his wife's grave he repairs her tomb and
then continues his life as a sniper who
is also a pacifist
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching